on judy's way home from school yesterday
she ran for half the distance
then she skipped for one-fourth of the
remaining distance and walked the rest
of the way home
she walked for a total of 360 feet what
is the distance between school and
judy's home and they say write the
answer in yards so this is a little
tricky right over here they say 360 feet
write the answer in yards and we have to
remind ourselves that one yard
one yard is equal to
three feet so just so we make sure we
don't make that careless mistake let's
put all of our information in yards
right now so 360 feet is how many yards
well there's three feet per yard so
we're just going to divide 360 feet by
three and so 360 divided by three is 120
120 yards and now we can continue to do
the whole problem in terms of yards
so let's think about it if we make the
entire distance so let me say that this
is her entire distance this is on her
way home from school so this is school
this is school and then let me draw a
line that shows the distance all the way
home
so
i want to draw it as large as possible
so we have room to
to write inside of it so that school
that that is home
and they first tell us that she ran for
half the distance so let's split this in
two
let's split that in two and so she ran
for half the distance this is the
distance that she ran
it's half the total distance
so she ran for half the distance
then they say
then she skipped for one fourth of the
remaining distance
so let's be clear the remaining distance
is what i haven't what i haven't filled
in an orange yet so let's mark that off
into fourths of the remaining distance
so that is half the remaining distance
that's one-fourth two-fourths or this is
one-fourth two-fourths three-fourths so
we took the remaining distance and we
divided it into fourths and they say
then she skipped for one-fourth of the
remaining distance
so this is the remaining distance after
running she skipped
she skipped for one-fourth of it
and then she walked the rest of the way
home so she walked the rest of the way
home this is the distance that she
walked
and this distance right over here is
120 yards
what is the distance between school and
judy's home
so there's a bunch of ways that you
could think about this when we talked
about the remaining distance after
running so this was the remaining
distance after she ran after this orange
part right over here you see that this
blue section is three-fourths of that
remaining distance 120 yards is
three-fourths of this remaining distance
so this is equal to
three-fourths of the remaining distance
remaining
remaining distance so how much is
one-fourth of each of those remaining
distance well this is three-fourths
one-fourth is going to be one-third of
this one-third of 120
is 40. so this distance right over here
is 40. this is 40. this is 40. notice 40
plus 40 plus 40 is 120 and this right
over here is also is also going to be
40. these are all in terms of yards
so the remaining distance is going to be
40 times 4 or 160 yards so this is 160
yards
now what is the total distance well this
160 yards the remaining distance after
she ran that's half the total distance
so this is 160 yards then this is going
to be
this is going to be
160 yards 160
yards as well so 160 yards plus 160
yards gives us a total distance from
school to home of 320
yards